laughing Wanda - aah screams no mattress
squeaks III showcase he said AHA joke
was joy to the key are they at all -
Wanda - are Square Enix's on the same
attendance by Otis to the title roaches
in Neosho fighters who were hanging up
inquire what's wrong sighs enjoy homo
Otto the question was not there
those are sang no mother was choking us
saw your husband Abbas destroy polishing
my show there is a moment in everyone's
life when we must make a choice that the
world's shape our destiny or fight to
become who we meant to be
throw the parachutes I know
hi my name is danielle shibez Oh game
director at a dose Montreal you've just
seen the beginning of Shadow the Tomb
Raider which will deliver on Lara cross
defining moment as she raised to stop a
Maya apocalypse bara will have to
confront a brutal jungle environment in
order to survive and even though that
she's more confident and more capable
she will still be outgunned and
outnumbered by Trinity she will have to
use everything she'll learn from the
jungle and use it in order to survive we
call this becoming one with the jungle
let's take a look what this means for
gameplay
jeez
base camps having someone to see me
doing this guff use the boost the signal
but I got it
what taxis together
got the team still has eyes on one of
Maya
we get more light in here kappa team
still has eyes on one of my agents
can we spell me a bit about a chicken
with my teeth jerk gives me something to
do
hey you know multis is access code Oh
103 5-3 Mike hey heading over there now
you some backup here
this place is empty body here looks
recent
starts up they can't be find out what's
going on
do take point faith away maybe there
50
[Music]
we hope that you like what you've just
seen so much depth to the combat and we
cannot wait to show you more there's new
traversal techniques like rappeling wall
running we even have a full 360-degree
underwater swimming which means full
underwater exploration and survival
we have also one of the biggest hub we
ever created in any Tomb Raider game
featuring a head and city and of course
we have tombs we have more of them and
they're deadlier than ever before but
for now we're going to leave you with a
video that will give you a taste of what
to expect out of shadow the two mater
and how Lara Croft becomes the Tomb
Raider that she's system to be
[Music]
the road ahead is uncertain
and fraught with danger we stand
together but we are the warriors of
light ready for whatever new challenges
and surprises await us
Odia
without our knowledge and expertise our
new friends will be hard-pressed to
contend with a foe from death is but a
minor inconvenience
- what's up doc
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
captain spirit is ready for battle
hi everyone my name is michelle cow and
my name is Bobby wells the two creative
directors of fleshes change I don't know
entertainment as you may know we have
just revealed the awesome adventures of
captain spirits it's a brand new story
in the life is changing lives and this
food experience will be available to
download for free on the 26th of June
tours life is strange is not a single
done off set of characters captain
spirit is always for introducing the
players to the mini stories we want to
tell in this expanded universe
captain spirit is not left his trench -
but it will be your first steps into
this world
the game is hiding many secrets and even
some links to the brand-new story and
characters of season 2 so make sure you
take all your time to explore we cannot
wait for you to experience Chris's story
we hope you will enjoy it and have a
great history and from all the lazy
strange team at tapenade thank you thank
you all right
[Music]
now I just need to make a cool costume
for captain spirit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the power of light
is best unveiled in our darkest hour
it seems that grief and tragedy have
followed you since birth
cruel fate dark plan has taught you to
the corners of the earth you've brushed
with death a thousand times yet still
you have your life
it is your fate to save this world for
this you must survive bright luminary
let the light shine on the world again
my strength you must fight fire becomes
fear
that matches his power and the
he's that of the darkness
it's time to claim your birthright
to save on money beckons
[Music]
[Music]
do not lose heart do not look back
[Music]
[Music]
very closely but to create the
characterizations both luminary we swear
to protect you while we live none shall
defeat you yep we're all in this
together sure is what you've got let's
do this lead on darling
fight from that the secret
and around it we make small objects that
could be girls for example or insects it
can be like 17th century
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
a masterpiece discovers a new home
we will take that our world from the
scourge of the machine
Laurie
[ __ ]
[Music]
wheresoever you wonder
and whoever you need along the way
the adventure will be one to remember
eight brain Souls
cleric scholar who merchant warrior
dancer apothecary seat
step into their shoes and explore the
realm of or Stara as you see fit
whose passing trend
[Music]
octopus trooper
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to Just Cause 4 in the return of
Rico Rodriguez rogue agent on a mission
that will challenge everything everyone
he knows
Rico has arrived in the fictional South
American country of solis the largest
and most breathtaking world we've ever
created every journey into soleus will
uncover history secrets and danger never
before has a Just Cause game offered
greater variety rich in all forms of
life at first glance Solis is a
beautiful location but scratch the
surface and you will uncover oppression
fear and violence all enforced by
Gabriela the leader of the private
militia organization the black hand just
cause for tapes destruction and physics
simulation to a whole new level with the
introduction of extreme weather
experience towering tornadoes that can
tear trees from the ground and level
bridges to sticks
awesome fort lightning unpredictable of
deadly sandstorms Rory blizzards
witness the spectacular destruction they
offer both the showers to Rico as well
as creating fun opportunities for
creative sandbox gameplay
totally new editions that offer extra
gameplay opportunities bulldozers car
transporters cranes and even wrecking
balls roll but in our world we have new
handling on bikes and cars as well as
exotic vehicles like jet skis micro Jets
Rico's grapple is now fully customizable
and has been overhauled to make it more
intuitive for newcomers while offering
greater depth for a more experienced
player the grapple now has more tethers
than ever before and the ability to
deploy booster rockets with all-new
airlifters making the grapples
incredibly powerful and creative tool
meanwhile a new story glues together our
freeform go anywhere do anything
gameplay that just cause is so famous
for and the stakes for Rico have never
been high
combat and Just Cause 4 is better than
this enemies now present a far more
intelligent threat to reach
each archetype comes with unique
abilities with AI designed to keep the
player off
Solis is a deeply advanced systemic
world everything you've seen from the
incredible physical eyes destruction to
unparalleled draw distance is powered by
the brand-new best-in-class open world
apex engine
my hand
welcome to Just Cause pool
go rock and dress down no one ordered a
child wave I did
[Music]
for every night there is a doll
for every question there is an answer
and for every door
is a key
is peeled
Wow
[Music]
a walking talking snowman you really are
alive
hello Olaf are these our friends no no
never met him
don't know anyone blue green or oddly
spike
that's amazing you can control ice
control it no all I ever do
is hurt people
yes
give me strength
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
still Sora that doesn't mean you should
change except the power you give him
find the hearts joined
[Music]
how did oh you're so what else except
light or darkness I know I want to know
me Roxas does exist his hearts inside my
heart in that case by all these nothing
Jesus more than Roxas is return of
course and Roxas yes for the virtual
world to be completely realized
Ansem the wise would have included Roxas
is full data in the construction
is that Nikki you're too late
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for joining the square-enix III
showcase 2018